[Music]
AWS CloudFormation provides developers
and system administrators in the easy
way to create and manage a collection of
related AWS resources it also allows you
to provision an update AWS resources and
in orderly and predictable fashion as if
it was a single entity AWS
CloudFormation stacks are a collection
of AWS resources that you can manage as
a single unit once deployed you can
modify and update them in a controlled
and predictable manner it's kind of like
applying version control to your AWS
infrastructure AWS CloudFormation
templates describe the resources that
you want to provision in your AWS
CloudFormation stacks and AWS provides
sample templates for you to use so you
don't have to worry about anything or
you can create your own by defining the
AWS resources the dependencies and the
parameters required for your application
to run so let's take a look at an AWS
CloudFormation
example so here we have Amazon
ElastiCache and there's two templates
there's one for memcache T and one for
Redis so let's take a look at the
memcache T so the template says it
creates an elastic Hashcash cluster with
the memcache Tianjin and deploys a
sample PHP application that connects to
the cache cluster now if you click on
the view button you get to see the JSON
code which makes up a cloud formation
template and then if you click on view
in designer you're presented with a
graphical representation of what you're
trying to create and if you click on the
launch stack guttin AWS will go and
actually launch all this for you
this is a very quick demonstration to
show how you can use cloud formation the
create and manage resources so if we go
to management tools and click on cloud
formation this brings us to the cloud
formation dashboard and we have a few
options we can design a template so we
can start from scratch and create our
own cloud formation stack or we can
create a stack using existing templates
or we can create a template from our
existing resources now this is very cool
so if you have a development environment
you could launch cloud format to create
a template from your existing resources
so that you can just press a button to
duplicate it whenever you need to it's
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a look at create a stack so we'll
click on that and we can either design
our own or we can choose a template so
we're going to use that and you can see
there's a few options here available for
us so what we're going to do is we're
going to do a single instance wordpress
blog and we can take a look at this
in the designer to see what it looks
like so i'm just going to open this up
in a new window okay so let me zoom out
i sort of disappear down here there it
is so this is a very simple cloud
formation template and it's going to
create an ec2 instance which is going to
be our web server which is going to host
the wordpress blog and it's going to
create a security group for us now if
you go down to the bottom we have a look
at the JSON we can see what it's doing
so it's allowing us to create this on in
all of these different instance types
then we have what's going to be allowed
where people can connect from the
database name who the DB user is etc is
there's all sorts of things going on
down there so let me just flip back to
CloudFormation and then we'll go through
the configuration steps okay so we now
click on next and this here is the
graphical representation of the JSON
code so we can give this stack a name so
we're just going to call it test because
we're not actually going to launch this
then the DB name so it's a WordPress DB
and the DB password
we can give it a password if we want to
let's just call it flat for now
DB user so who we want to be able to
connect I'm going to call that admin
then we get to choose the instance type
so we can choose any of these instance
types for our wordpress blog and then we
need to give it the key so we'll use our
simply learn key pair and the SSH
location so what IP range do we want it
to be accessible from an SSH so we could
tighten this down to say chess my IP
address but we're just going to leave it
open then we click on next we get to
give it a tag if we want to and then we
get to the creation stage so we get to
review is telling us it's using this
template as a description of what it
does there's a warning here it says this
template creates an Amazon ec2 instance
and you will be billed to the resources
if you use it now it's worth remembering
some of these cloud formation templates
have some pretty high powered servers
involved in them so when you launch them
you may incur some significant costs so
just be aware of that then you have the
details that we typed in and then when
we're done you just click create and it
would create that stack for you and this
concludes the demonstration for cloud
formation hey once you become an expert
in cloud computing then subscribe to
simply learn Channel and click here to
watch more such videos turner it up and
get certified in cloud computing click
here